PROFESSOR: The
arguments that we just
reviewed for proving
inclusion-exclusion
by looking at how many
times points are counted
can be made perfectly rigorous.
In fact, we'll do that
in a later segment,
but it's interesting
and good practice
to realize that they
can also be proved just
from some simple set
theoretic identities using
the ordinary disjoint sum rule.
So how am I going to prove the
inclusion-exclusion principle
for two sets?
The size of A union
B is the size of A
plus the size of B minus
the size of A intersect B,
and the idea is just break up
A union B into disjoint sets
because once they're disjoint
sets, I can add up their sizes.
So if we look at A
union B, A union B
can be expressed as the
union of two disjoint sets,
namely A-- the round
blue circle-- and what's
left-- the points in B that
are not in A, so this lighter
orange-colored region.
So A and B union and B minus
A-- so these are the points in A
and these are the points that
are in B that are not in A
are two disjoint sets
whose union is A union B.
That means that I
know the size of this.
It's just the size of A
plus the size of B minus A
because they're disjoint, so
we conclude by the sum rule
that the size of A union B
is equal to the size of A
plus the size of B minus A.
So now I need a
little lemma that
says that the size of B
minus A is the size of B
minus the size of
A intersection B.
If I get that, then I've
proved inclusion-exclusion
because now I have A plus
B minus A intersection B.
So we need a lemma.
The lemma says that
the size of B minus A
is equal to the size of B minus
the size of A intersect B.
So here we're back
to the Venn diagram.
A is blue, B is reddish,
and the intersection region,
that lens-shaped region,
is shown in purple,
and we want to prove this lemma.
Well, again, what we can do
is look at the set B broken up
into two pieces.
B can be expressed as a
disjoint union of the part of B
that's in A union, the part
of B that's not in A. That is,
for any set B and
any set A, B is
equal to the B points
that are in the A
and the B points that are not
in A covers all the cases.
And this, again, is
a disjoint union.
So we conclude immediately from
the sum rule that the size of B
is equal to the size
of B intersection
A plus the size of B minus
A. And then just transposing
this term for the
size of B minus A
to the left-hand side of the
equality, I've proven the lemma
and we're done.
Now, inclusion-exclusion
for three sets,
we've said before it's this
slightly more complicated thing
where you've got a sum of
the intersections of one
set minus the sizes of the
intersections of two sets
plus the size of the
intersection of three sets.
And that generalizes to the
following somewhat messy
formula, but let's look
at it closely together.
If I want to know what's
the size of A1 through An--
if I have n sets potentially
overlapping A1 A2 through An
and I want their union, and I
can express the union of them
in terms of a sum of
sizes of intersections,
and here's the formula.
Let's read this slowly together.
So this is a sum over every
possible subset of the indices
1 through n that's not empty.
So this sum is ranging over S,
and it can do it in any order.
It's typical to write the sum
where you sum up first all
the sets S of size 1 and then
sum up all the sets S of size 2
and sum-- but that's
not necessary.
We just sum in any order for
every subset of the indices,
the size of the intersection
of the Ai's that
are in this set of
indices specified by S.
So this is just the intersection
of those A's that s specifies.
Now, what's the sign of
that size of intersection?
As we said, if it's of odd size,
I want it to count positively.
So if I take minus 1
to the odd size plus 1,
I get an even power of minus
1, so it comes out to be 1.
If, on the other
hand, the size of S
is even-- so I'm
taking an intersection
of an even number of sets--
then this number to the plus 1
is odd.
I'm taking minus
1 to an odd power,
and sure enough, I'm
getting the negative sign
on all the intersections
of odd size.
So that's what this rather
concise but hairy formula
looks like.
Here we have an intersection
over the Ai's where
the i is specified by
the set S of indices,
and I sum up these terms over
every possible nonempty set
S. That is the generalized
form of inclusion-exclusion
for n sets.
Now, how do we prove this?
Well, there's lots
of ways to prove it.
The simplest way is to do
it actually by induction.
It's not very hard
to do by induction.
You just use the two-set version
of inclusion-exclusion, which
we've proved rigorously
using the disjoint sum rule,
and you go from the union of
the first n sets plus the nth
and apply the formula and
simplify, and that works fine.
The other problem with it is
[? it's ?] not really very
informative.
You prove the theorem all right.
As is frequently the case
with induction proofs,
you have the right
induction hypothesis,
the proof is kind of
mechanical, but you don't really
learn much from it-- not
always, but in this case,
I don't think you do.
A second way to do it is by
using the binomial theorem
and counting.
This is a way to make rigorous
the argument that said,
OK, we counted two points in
the intersection of two things
twice, so we had to
subtract them away,
and then that meant
that we were not
counting the things that were
in the intersection of three
not at all, and so on.
And we've talked through
that argument informally,
and I will do that in a
next segment of making
that argument a little
bit more precise to prove
the general theorem.
And--
[AUDIO OUT]
Law from algebra, we can just
look at a product of sums
and understand how it expands
into a sum of products
by the distributivity law.
And that's worked out in a
problem that is in the text,
and I'm not going to
do that in a video.